Okay,
so now I have played with kids that
haven't had any rough and tumble play
and it's really hard to play with them
partly because they're there,
they're easily frightened,
you know,
they'd like to play.
I know how to play with kids.
They'd like to play.
They're pretty hepped up on it,
you know,
and they,
they really excited,
especially about physical plane,
but they're awkward,
you know,
so you play with them,
they stick their thumb in your eye or
you know,
or they cry really easily with nothing
really happens and like they just don't
have it together.
A kid that has done a lot of physical
interaction,
physical plane,
that kid,
it's a different sort of kid because the
first thing the kid knows,
it's not a rule.
The first thing the kid knows is how
forceful can he be with you so that it's
exciting and interesting and fun,
but it's not too much.
And that's really an interesting
question because actually to really play
a good game like a physical contact
game,
like wrestling with a kid is that you
want to let that kid come right up to
the edge of hurting you.
And the closer the kid gets to the edge,
the more fun it is for both because the
kid will give you a whack and who you
know and that's,
it's good,
you know,
and then maybe he'll give you a harder
whack to see if he can get away with it.
The kids will often,
they'll come up to you,
whack you and then run away and then
they'll look and if you're laughing then
they'll come back and try a harder one
and then you know,
they're doing it incrementally because
it's exploratory behavior.
And part of the exploration is okay,
what our bodies like.
And the answered that is,
well,
what can you get away with doing to
them?
But it's a more sophisticated answer to
which is what can you get away with
doing to them in a way that allows you
to continue to explore without fear or
punishment.
And without blowing the whole game to
bits,
okay,
so how do you figure that out?
You do not talk about it because you
can't,
you have to act it out.
It's like so.
So the kids hitting you in wrestling and
pulling your hair and doing all these
things and you're modifying its behavior
very,
very carefully and,
and,
and minuscule detail.
And then you get a kid who can wrestle
like mad and they're fun to play with.
They bounce around like a dog that will
bite you.
You know,
a good well trained dog you can really
play with and you can play with them
rough.
And it's a blast.
The dog has a good time.
That person has a good time.
It's like excellent.
That's a socialized dawn.
So the other thing that kids learn
learns,
which is quite cool,
is what hurts them and what doesn't and
how afraid can they be and still have
fun.
So you know,
when you're wrestling with a kid,
you've put them,
you know,
you put them face down,
you put your elbow on them,
you bend them around,
you throw them in the air and catch
them.
You know,
you've grabbed him by the leg and maybe
you pull them over and you know,
and what you're showing the kid is
here's a bunch of things that your body
can do and it's okay that they're,
they're being done that isn't going to
hurt you and you're not talking about,
you're showing them and so the kid gets
kind of about what he or she can
withstand physically and the difference
between pain and not paying and the
difference between fear and not fear and
when something is threatening and when
it's not.
It's very sophisticated.
It's very sophisticated behavior and
that's partly why kids love to play.
Now.
One of the things that's happened,
which is you know,
an indication of a deep sickness in our
society is that I used to work in a
daycare center right when I was about
your age because I really like kids and
they like to play with me because I know
how to play with them.
And so one of the things I would do with
the little kids was I would draw them
horrible monsters,
right?
Like big teeth things on.
I just sketched them out.
They weren't any works of art,
you know,
but those damn kids,
they would line up to get a picture of a
monster,
draw me a picture of the monster,
drop me a picture of a monster.
It's like they love those little
pictures of monsters so that I was
pretty funny.
And other thing I would do is play with
them.
I'd take them out in the yard and grab
an arm and a leg and spin them around
and bend them over and,
you know,
twist them around and let them crawl on
me.
And um,
there's always one kid in the group that
couldn't do that though.
He's like,
he hadn't been paid attention to enough,
you know.
So he was,
I think it was like a Taoist uncarved
block,
very vague and ill defined and clunky
and so kid like that,
you know,
you'd sit down,
it's so sad you sit down and you're
interacting with the kids and that kid
comes along sort of lumping along,
you know,
like this and they plop plop on your lap
and they like,
they're about as sophisticated as like a
six month old,
you know?
And they're quite annoying,
you know,
which is a horrible thing because
they're so desperate for attention and
it's too late often by the time
therefore it's like,
good luck fixing that man.
It's not going to happen,
you know,
and those kids are just screwed because
what happens to them is they're so lumpy
and ill formed and,
and uncomfortable in their body and
socially clueless and inattentive and
blind and ignored and resentful that no
other kids will play with them.
And it's no wonder because there are
other kids are way the hell up on the
play development trend.
And so their board staff by them,
it's like playing with a nine month old,
which,
which kids will do,
you know,
but that's not pure play.
And so those kids just drift off.
They get,
they stay on the outside of the peer
group and they never get into it.
They never get into it.
So very,
very ugly.
And so now in daycare centers you can't
touch the kids.
It's like what the hell,
you know?
Well why?
Well,
because he can't distinguish play for
molesting.
It's like who can't distinguish that,
you know?
And what are you going to do?
You're not gonna.
You're gonna deprive.
The kids have play because of your
stupid paranoia.
That's the whole.
That's the whole process,
right?
Brilliant.
You know what you're doing is you're
teaching children that adults are so
dangerous that they can't be trusted to
be near you.
That's a lovely thing to teach children,
especially because they're going to be
adults.